the luca bakery in lujan about an hour's
drive west of buenos aires was founded
in 1875 by marcos's great great
grandfather angelo an immigrant from
lombardy in italy
it's overcome several economic crises
and marcos is confident it'll survive
the one now unfolding
argentinians are perhaps very good at
coping because we're used to living this
way and maybe because our grandparents
have managed to survive every one of
these crises they had to face
but it's tough he has to be alert to
increases in the price of almost
everything especially flour and fuel
plus the argentine pistol weakening
against the us dollar while keeping his
30-plus staff and his customers happy
bread is one of life's necessities
whatever the cost it was in 1875 and
continues to be at the heart of the
battle to keep prices affordable and the
community functioning
the bakery workers like these ovens at
4am seven days a week there have been
many changes in the past 147 years but
some things remain constant
[Applause]
these scales for instance made in london
even before luca was founded and of
course customers with an appetite but
less and less money to spend
what we do now is consume less we don't
buy as much as we used to so we keep
costs down or we take advantage of the
promotions
hyperinflation at more than 3 thousand
percent hit argentina in 1989 then
social and economic catastrophe in 2001.
inflation is the result is the
thermometer it's it's like when you have
when you're sick and you have fever you
measure fever you measure inflation in
this case but it's not the cause
the cause is the the underlying monetary
and fiscal policies which
bring generate this inflation both
argentina and the luca bakery are
victims of crippling foreign debt and
the war in ukraine which saw the price
of flower rocket
bread is something that's been around
for hundreds of years and will continue
to be sold for several more centuries
yet
because it must and it's difficult to
resist food this good whatever the price
daniel schwein al jazeera lucan
argentina